every day in organizations all around
the globe impromptu teams are formed
that must flexibly collaborate
regardless of shift changes emergency
situations side load Specialties or
cross-sector Partnerships we call this
Dynamic form of collaboration teaming to
it is a requirement for delivering
Optimal Care yet it doesn't necessarily
come naturally Professionals in the
healthcare and life science Industries
know that their work is a team sport
what they may not know is that the
science of teaming can help them thrive
I discovered that outside Healthcare had
developed a whole bunch of Sciences that
supported continual Improvement and
breakthroughs that Healthcare just had
never learned being a leader does not
mean being a subject matter expert your
job is to see the whole board and
everybody else gets to go deep and you
need to go Broad
by learning from experts in healthcare
and business you will understand how you
and your colleagues can create and
Implement a process of teaming within
your organization
teamwork is not some kind of a corporate
catchphrase teamwork and what we do
translates an improvement of human lives
by the end of the course you'll
appreciate what enables effective
teamwork and why teamwork can fail
you'll be able to articulate the
importance of psychological safety and a
joint problem-solving orientation and
rethink the role of a leader and the
organization in the context of teaming
don't leave teaming up to Chance draw on
the science